Are we looking at a cabinet position what's going on here?
Uh, so that's, there's absolutely nothing has been, you know, uh,
discussed in like a hyper official level, but unofficially, um,
in the conversations we've had people like,
we'd love to have you on the team when a boom work with you.
Like things like that. I love. So what do you want to be.
Dream? What's your dream position there?
So what I've been saying, uh,
to folks is that I want to try and speed us up on these technology
issues. And we could, you know,
I think the three of us could talk about this stuff for hours,
but our government is just so out to launch on technology issues.
And so that could be AI.
That could be the selling and reselling of our data that could be,
uh, media and social media.
That could be mental health issues that are attendant with smartphone adoption
on the part of teenage girls. They're all of these issues.
Does that cabinet position even exist?
It does not. And then there's a good part. Um, but there,
there is an advantage there because, uh, if they created a new role for me,
then it's not like they'd be blocking anyone out because it's not like they're
like 15 people being like, Hey,
I really want to be in innovation and technology.
We created a new cabinet, a branch.
Yes. That is something. So yeah, you can, that's the short answer.
I mean, that's, that seems like a great,
a great place to go and perfect gang style cabinet of technology,
um, secretary of technology.
Secretary of technology and innovation, actually the Washington post, just,
just put that out there today. They said, here's the cabinet we recommend.
And they said, Andrew Yang, like a secretary of technology,
innovation that devises all of the other cabinet.
That would be amazing.
I'm lobbying for that from now on.
Can we actually.
I don't think Joe would CA I think Joe could garner a lot of, of, uh,
support by, by making that happen.
Do we have any input in making that happen? Like,
can we do anything if people were to,
if there was a groundswell of support being like, Hey Joe,
like if you signal to everyone that you're going to name Andrew,
the secretary of technology and innovation that would help us vote for you. Um,
they might do it because there's no reason not to really. I mean, like, again,
it's not like a role that exists presently. And so, you know,
it would make him seem forward thinking so enough people and this stuff,
you know, it's not, uh, that under the radar, in the sense, again,
the Washington post just recommended it. So,
and when I've spoken to people that like me, they were like, well,
this makes me more excited about Joe. If I bring you on in this capacity.
If you get this cabinet position, which we're all hoping for, tell me, tell me,
what are the first things that you think like you're sitting down in America,
you're part of the cabinet. What do we need to do first?
What is the most pressing things we need to address in this country? America?
I mean, clearly it's casually for universal basic income, you know, it's like,
that's just like the simple thing. Um, it sounds, you know, that's,
to me the single best thing we could do for people.
So let's say if you say something technology-related then I, you know,
I I'd actually choose something related,
which is what we talked about earlier around the fact that we didn't actually
have a system set up to get people money.
So we use the IRS check distribution system. Um,
and I think it's bad for our confidence in our government that it sucks so
bad. And a lot of these things where like,
if you go to your bank's website or whatever,
you just expect it to work generally a certain level. Um, and then,
so you'd be like, well, why isn't the government to have something? So,
one thing I'd love to invest in would be essentially a citizen portal where if
there was something like we're trying to get you money or trying to get you
information,
or so the lamest version of this would be a citizen portal where it's
essentially like,
here are all of these links to other government websites that you can go to.
Like, that would be the absolute worst version. The best version would be. So
like one of those boards where it's like,
here's a pretty good flurry of websites to go to you. But
like the good Virgin would be like a,
a slick interface where like, you know,
like the information from let's call it your tax returns, uh,
or, uh, from, uh,
the passport office or wherever the heck, like could actually be compiled. Uh,
because part of the thing that makes me angry right now is that like,
you're hearing a lot of messages from folks all the time associated with
politics. We're just like, trust us. Trust is you got to trust us.
And it's like, well,
like you guys don't really deliver the same level as like some of the other
organizations I've used to interacting with. Um,
so I would love to try and help the government deliver at like a,
on a technical level, because I think it would be enormous for our confidence.
Uh, so that would be something I would love to,
especially if it was tied to universal basic income,
because I think that there is a relationship where, um,
we need to actually know who you are, know how to get you money,
have to have some kind of secure relationship with you and interface with you.
If we're going to try and, you know, add value.
Don't you think the big problem is that all of our elected officials and
even, you know, uh, Joe by, I mean, how old is Joe?
He's like 74 or something like that. I mean.
Um, I think, I think he's, uh, like 76 or 77, I think.
Um, I don't want to misspeak. I should know that. I mean, he's.
In his, Oh, you're looking it up. Yeah.
Okay. Let's see. I mean, maybe one of your team.
Yeah. Look it up. Uh, Zach he's 77 years old. Whoa.
So, so don't you think that's the, it,
we need young people who understand this,
like a seventies I've no 77 year old people. They're not interested in cash app.
Do you know what I mean? They understand checks and that's not their fault.
It's just the way it is.
But I think like we have this tendency of electing,
especially lately old people to office, even Donald Trump is in his seventies.
Right. He's like 72, 73 years old. I mean, these,
although he's a little to be, Oh, 74, somehow.
He doesn't somehow Trump, I guess.
He's got a young energy, such an. He's got that energy that associated with.
He does a lot. He does a lot with this. He does like a spray tan and that hair.
Yeah.
It's used to the cameras. I think he just on camera.
I think it comes off like that. I'll re say, I never met him in person,
but I have a feeling if you saw him in person, he would look that age to you.
Do give him credit. He is, he has a more youthful spirit for whatever reason.
And he's on Twitter. That's pretty, that's pretty Epic. But that being said,
I don't think Trump uses cash app either. And so what we need is, is,
is younger people. I really truly think we just need younger people.
And that's one of the reasons not, that was one of the reasons why I liked you.
Right. And one of the reasons I like AOC is that we just like AOC.
Does Instagram live every like super frequently to talk
directly with her? Uh, yeah.
She's like a digital native, uh,
think the average age of a member of Congress is 62 to your point, Ethan.
So it was not just presidential candidates, right?
Someone called it a gerontocracy take a rule by the old,
we essentially have a gerontocracy in the United States of America for a number
of reasons. Uh, one of the main reasons is that after you get into Washington,
you just try and stay there forever. Uh,
and it's actually very hard to defeat an incumbent. So you have folks,
uh, like, um, Nancy Pelosi I believe is, uh, around Joe's age.
Um, and she looks great, but she does,
but our leaders are of a nother generation, uh,
because of the way the structure is, the, the,
the structures are set up. And it's one reason why I'm for term limits, um,
where you should go to DC as a term of service,
get something done and then get out, uh,
and it would help keep our legislators more current and fresh and modern to your
point, Ethan, because if you go to DC,
you'll find it is not exactly a tech friendly town. Uh, you know, you go,
I'll tell a story that was going to make you angry,
but it will be totally consistent with your understanding of the world. So, uh,
so I was on the trail and then there was like this, uh, uh,
Asian kid was like, you know, mid twenties maybe. Um,
and he interned at his congressional office and then they asked him to like, uh,
do, do something, um, uh,
like answering messages or data related, like in the office.
And he was smart.
So he set up like a program to like automate the process and make it so that
okay, like this thing will like happen more seamlessly and like, you know,
like less labor, um, this'll be great.
And then they yelled at him for it and said like, no,
we didn't want you to do that. Like, uh, like where,
where we actually preferred the way that like the other person, uh,
could just understand and just like sit there and like,
just pick at it all the time. And he was like, what the hell is going on? I did,
there's like a congressional office. And so he left, he now works at Facebook.
He like went and worked in DC for like a summer, was like,
they are freaking stuck in like the stone age. Let me get the hell outta here.
And then he like peaced out to Silicon Valley. So like that,
that is the general culture in DC where you go there and you feel like you just
rewound, uh, like a, a number of years.
And if you go into some of these government agencies, it's much,
much worse because some of them have been underfunded.
So you have like very strange patchwork technologies, uh,
from past years, uh, you know, like, I mean, I might be exaggerating,
but probably not my much it'd be like windows,
like 2005 or whatever that you go in and they'll just be used up all over,
um, in, in different, uh, different government organizations. So it,
so that's, that's the government we have. Um, and like you said before,
it's like not really anyone's fault. Um,
but we need to try and speed them up. Um,
and if I'm in position to try and move that in a better direction,
like I've taken and do everything I could.
That sounds really we have to, yeah, we have to do that. I mean, I think the,
I think we would probably miss that the rate of technology has Sur as
past our,
our people it's been going so fast that it's past them. Right.
When Joe Biden was a one in his forties,
even fifties, like 25, 26, seven years ago,
it was a, we were in 1995. I mean,
I don't even know that smartphones were popular then I don't think, no,
not even close, not even close. Right. So, I mean, in,
in his own experience and in government,
the technology as ran around him like 30 times,
so it's a new, it's a new world.
They got rid of the office of technology assessment in 1995,
the year you just described the perfect time to get rid of it. Yeah.
But they had a,
they had a department that advised members of Congress on what technology,
you know, they should care about and like opinions,
like why didn't they do that?
Why did they get rid of the office of technologies? That's been, uh, you know,
like, it, it, it was like to quote save money,
which is like the most asinine thing in the world,
because the budget of the entire thing was like 25 million.
It was like a drop in the bucket.
You just had some smarter people around telling you. It's like, Hey,
so you know where legislators get their technology guidance from now the
technology companies and the technology companies are like,
do absolutely nothing because everything is perfect.
And that the legislators are like, yeah, that sounds about right.
Perfect. Yeah. That whatever requires the least of me. Yeah. So,
and especially if you're donating $25 million to my campaign, that's fantastic.
There was a period,
and it's been interesting to see the pendulum swing somewhat.
So Silicon Valley could do no wrong for a long time.
Where do you see is cause it's, they're just like, Oh,
you're like the innovators, you're the super value creators. And you're rich as.
And you donate to my campaign. So let's just like,
leave you the heck alone and just sing your praises every chance we get. Uh,
and then that pendulum has swung because of, uh, like, uh,
Facebook screwing, some things up and, uh, and, and some other problems. Uh,
so now everyone's starting to turn on a turn towards them and be like,
wait a minute. Like, you know,
is this really been like cool that Amazon is, you know, like, uh.
Andrew Yang, future secretary of technology and innovation
love this one.
Essentially. And if that happened,
I certainly have U2 and a lot of other people to thank.
But the big thing right now is just for us to help each other,
try and get through this mess and stay strong and healthy ourselves.
Cause you can't help anyone if you can, you know, like help yourself.
But then if you do have the capacity to help others,
please do lend someone a hand. Cause like someone in your life needs a hand.
Can we count on an interview from Washington DC a year from now?
Yeah, definitely.
Like if I'm the secretary of technology innovation,
uh, then we'll have so much to talk about and then leave,
it ended up being like one of these types of being like, Hey, send me ideas,
citizens, because I am now.
Yeah. And Andrew, if there are UFO's, will you tell us that you have.
If I find out there are UFO's, uh,
I will tell people because we all know they're there already.
You let me ask you that.
Yes. If someone's like, okay, Andrew, we're going to give,
we're going to tell you that UFO's and the aliens and all this crazy exists,
but you can't tell anyone. Do you tell us.
Depends on who it is really. I mean, you know, it's someone I can be like,
sorry, man. Like I just had to tell people that'd be.
But there's no way you would actually be able to tell us that you see the
problem.
I do see the problem. If they bring me into the circle of UFO trust,
then it's hard to run outside of the circle and tell Ethan in Hilo.
Or you die. Just get the truth out there. Yeah. Blink twice your on your death.
Bed. Um, that done deal. Deathbed,
UFO confession. Yes. There we go.
All right. Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation.
If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.